okay so one of the most interesting it
got a weirdest work from home stories
has to be this company called relativity
space they are a rocket startup in
Southern California just outside of
downtown Los Angeles they are actually
trying to 3d print an entire rocket
using these giant machines that are sort
of Westworld like in the midst of this
pandemic and the work-from-home
situation their technology actually
looks like an advantage a major
advantage in that they've been able to
keep running these robots autonomously
just having one person go by the factory
every now and again to keep the robots
fed it's explained how all this works in
the company's vision we're gonna talk to
Tim Ellis who is the co-founder and CEO
of relativity
[Music]
I obviously I cover the space industry
really close and and it's very exciting
time base X just had a historic launch
and then there's this flood of other
rocket startups that are coming and and
I've been following you guys for a while
you guys are a little bit different than
the other rocket startups can you sort
of explain what relativity does I
founded relativity back at the beginning
of 2016 and my co-founder was actually
working at SpaceX on the crew dragon
program I was at Blue Origin the problem
we saw in the industry is that really
for the last 60 years no one's actually
changed how Rockets are manufactured
you know there's reusability there's
other kind of rocket technologies which
are are new and very disruptive but we
really felt 3d printing a whole rocket
was going to be the next big disruption
in the industry you know if you if you
go so where even like SpaceX which is a
super modern aerospace company you know
they do 3d print some stuff it is
particularly around the engines but you
know a lot of stuff is done by hand yes
that's right other companies we've seen
are probably in the single digits you
know maybe as low as 0.1 percent of the
rocket is actually 3d printed by mass
we're actually targeting printing 95% of
our rocket I'm so almost everything
other than the electronics we're
targeting not just printing 95% of the
rocket but doing it from raw material to
a finished
rocket and the factory and only 60 days
and that compares to about two years in
a traditional factory the 3d printers
that we ended up developing entirely
in-house use big robots that come from
industrial car automation or other sort
of industrial automation and then we've
actually had to write our own software
and then all of the control algorithms
to to basically you know wherever the
robot moves around we have a metal wire
that gets fed in and then we actually
use plasma to melt the wire and then
that solidifies and so essentially you
know now we can code the robots and
using pretty sophisticated controls
wherever the robot moves around we can
actually
prints are our fuel tank and it's very
very fast as far as like why somebody
hasn't done this before I remember what
you guys got started I think even still
today maybe it's fair to say I mean
there's there's people who are skeptical
of this approach obviously these Rockets
are it's a controlled explosion can you
3d print something that's stable enough
you know we've actually already produced
a full-scale second stage structure with
the common dome and done proof testing
to show that it can hold to the pressure
and stresses of flight and we've done
something like 300 engine tests to date
all 3d printed so we're actually proving
the tech works during the pandemic I
mean I know a lot of the aerospace
companies were able to stay relatively
open if they were doing sort of stuff
that had like a national-security kind
of implication or national interest what
was it like for you guys have you been
able to have employees in the factory we
actually took a pretty proactive
approach to the the pandemic so around
March 6 to March 9th we actually started
making everyone go home and work from
home so people unplugged their desktop
so we're actually very cloud forward
company in our architecture which lets
us operate the 3d printers remotely
anyway so we're actually very well
prepped for that prioritizing the the
health and safety of our employees we
are deemed essential business but we
actually never had to have more than one
person in the factory at a time to keep
printing and we've also seen a very
minimal supply chain disruptions because
we have extremely few suppliers there's
really just not that many processes that
we need to build a rocket since we're
printing everything you know we have
very few raw materials it's actually
only three raw metals for the entire
rocket it's so so elands long stated
goal is to eventually create a human
colony on Mars and I know you have Mars
aspirations as well I mean reflected on
why Jordan and I had started the company
we had this core theory that you know
SpaceX was going to Mars I'm actually
super confident
and I'm really inspired by that but you
know every animation I saw you know had
astronauts fly there and then you know
they were they had kind of land and then
the ladder would roll down and then it
would fade to black and that became you
know sort of this thing that stuck in my
mind that man there need to be dozens to
hundreds of companies working on
different pieces of the puzzle of going
to Mars and so that's where we came up
with our vision there's a company which
is to 3d print the first rocket made on
Mars and I'm sure Rockets not the first
thing we're gonna make I mean we're
probably gonna make water storage tanks
you know habitat vessels spare parts
other things that just help early early
sort of settlements get going
how old are you now I just turned 30 I
just turned 30 a few weeks yeah yeah
it's so so what age do you expect to be
when you 3d print your first water
storage tank on Mars yeah and honestly I
think it's actually gonna happen faster
than some of the the human spaceflight
can so I think it could actually happen
within a decade honestly my life
philosophy has been you know if the
future is not really happening fast
enough well we knew like why don't we
just create it you know we could
actually be that company that makes this
happen
you